everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem permutation in a
string and there's actually two
solutions to this problem one is the 26
times n solution and there's another
solution that's actually just big o of n
now we know that a constant number here
doesn't actually affect the overall time
complexity but that being said i'm still
going to focus on the slightly more
optimal solution uh because it's a
little bit more difficult but it's also
interesting and it's a pattern that's
actually used in other leak code
problems as well so we're given two
strings s1 and s2 and all we want to do
is return true if the string s2 contains
a permutation of s1 and we return false
if that's not the case now you can get
bogged down and really confused with the
explanation of this problem like
focusing a ton on permutations but i'm
going to try to simplify this for you
immediately without going down too many
rabbit holes and let's actually take a
look at this first example so we see
that s1 is the target string that's what
we're trying to look for we're looking
for a permutation of this string
somewhere inside of s2 can we find it
now what does permutation mean well we
could actually you know create a
permutation of the string which would be
really complex and annoying
but we see that over here there actually
is a substring of s2 and it's a
permutation that matches s1 it's ba
right the exact same characters just in
a different order which is perfectly
fine now by the way a b itself
technically counts as a permutation of
itself so this string is also allowed
but since you kind of see what we're
really just looking for is is there a
substring of the exact same size so this
is two characters so we have to look for
a substring of two characters here right
we can't just take three characters and
say that that's the permutation but you
know we're looking for a window same
size as this and it has to contain the
exact same characters as s1 just maybe
in a different order now does that kind
of sound familiar to you well it's the
same thing as looking for an anagram
right we're just looking for the exact
same characters we don't care about what
order they're in right so it's looking
for an anagram so we can actually use a
typical sliding window technique we're
going to look at every window in s2
that's the exact same size as s1 so in
this case length 2. so we're going to
look at the first two characters then
the next two characters the next two etc
etc until we find an exact match with s1
now if we were actually comparing the
exact characters that would be pretty
annoying the time complexity in that
case would let's say be n times m where
n is the size of s2 m is the size of s1
because we're looking at every single
window but we can do it a little bit
better we can reduce it to be 26 times n
if we use a hash map because actually in
this problem it's written all the way at
the bottom of the description so it's
not on screen but they tell us that all
the characters in both of the strings
are going to be limited to lowercase a
through lowercase z so therefore the
size of our hashmap is going to be at
most size 26. there's only 26 characters
so as we build that hash map we're
actually going to have two hash maps
we're going to have one hash map for s1
which is going to stay the exact same
we're also going to have a second hash
map for s2 which is going to have the
characters of the current window that
we're at so every time we create a
window right each time we shift our
window to the right we're only just
adding one character and maybe removing
the character that was on the left and
then once we have those two hash maps
we're going to compare them if they are
equal which is a 26 operation right
there's only 26 characters and so that's
where we get this time complexity from
but there actually is a better way this
solution is doable it's easy to code up
and you can do so if you would like but
i'm going to show you the slightly more
optimal solution which is actually not
even going to have this 26 it's just
gonna be big o of n so let's look at the
big o of n solution and it's actually
similar to the previous solution we
discussed we're actually going to still
have two hash maps one for s1 so as you
can see we counted the occurrences of
each character we call it s1 count so we
have one a we have one b and one c so we
filled our hash map with the same values
and rs2 hash map is empty because first
we're going to set our window here and
then we're going to continue to shift it
by one each time but the difference here
is we're not actually going to be
comparing the two hash maps together we
won't need to because we're going to
keep track of one more variable we're
going to call it matches
we're basically going to have a little
shortcut initially this is going to be
set to zero i'll just create a box for
it even though it's just going to be a
single
value but we might be updating it to
other values but this matches variable
is basically going to be a shortcut
that's going to allow us to not have to
compare the entire hash maps each time
which we know in the worst case could be
a 26 operation having to look through
every single character of the hashmaps
because this matches variable is
actually gonna maintain the total number
of equal characters in each of these
hash maps and actually even though i
didn't draw the entire
map for s1 and s2 in this case because
actually we know that there's a through
z there's 26 characters and i didn't
actually draw the entire thing but we
are gonna
you know fill in the values in the code
because we know that the rest of the
characters in s1 are gonna be of count
zero right and matches is gonna tell us
the exact number of matches of each
character between the two hash maps so
we want to know does
the a count of s1 and of s2 match if it
does match then that's a plus one if it
doesn't match then that's not a plus one
right and we want to know the number of
matches for every single character and
we want to know that initially right it
could be 26 matches or it could be zero
matches right it could be any value in
between but once we have 26 matches that
means that for some window in s2 and by
looking at it we know that this is going
to be the window we know that this
window has 26 matches with this window
because they both have a single a
character a single b character a single
c character and for the other remaining
23 characters they have
they both have zero of those characters
so therefore they have 26 matches that's
what we care about and we can do that
with a single variable without having to
look through the entire hashmap let me
show you the algorithm to do that it's
pretty straightforward actually so first
thing we're going to do is actually just
look at the first three characters of s2
and then fill up our hash map so we have
a single b we have a single a and we
have a single x now you can see that
this is what our hash maps actually look
like we have looked at the first three
characters and now what we're actually
going to do for the only time we are
actually going to iterate through both
of these hash maps comparing each
character we actually do have to do that
at least one time but it's a single 26
operation so and then after that we'll
only have to just iterate through this
string so the overall time complexity is
going to be n plus 26 which we know is
going to be equal to big o of n uh it's
it's definitely better than if we were
just doing 26 times n okay so we're
gonna look at every character a they
both have one a they both have one b
s one has a single c
but s two does not have any c's so
therefore they have two matches a and b
but c is not a match then we're going to
look at all the other characters after c
and we're actually going to see that yes
there is a match
right because they both have zero d's
they both have zero e's they have zero
f's etc etc but then we're going to get
to x okay
this has a single x but s1 does not have
any x's that's not a match but they both
have zero y's and zero z's so all in all
they actually matched every single
character except for c and except for x
those were the only characters they
didn't match so actually initially we
have 24 matches next we're gonna look
we're gonna take our window which was
like this and we're gonna shift it to
the right by one when we shift it we're
obviously removing a character from the
s2 window we're removing a b now as we
make changes to the count we want to
know does it affect the number of
matches so here we have one right which
was equal to what it was supposed to be
in s1 as well but now we're now changing
it to a zero so therefore it's not
matching with what it previously was
matching with therefore our matches
total is actually going to be updated
now to be 23 we're decrementing it by
one okay but we also added a character a
y does this affect our matches was this
a character we were looking for well
let's increment our i by one and we see
that now it's one but what was the y
value in s1's count it was equal to 0 so
now we actually created another mismatch
so actually the total number of matches
is gonna be 22 now and now we're going
to actually shift one more time so this
a is no longer gonna be in our window
now we're gonna have x y z in our window
so we remove the a a count is now gonna
be set to zero we created another
mismatch so our matches count is now
gonna be 21 but we added a z so
our z count is one but the z count in s1
is zero therefore we created another
mismatch so now our total number of
matches is actually going to be 20. now
let's shift our window one more time
let's chop off this x so x count is now
going to be set to zero so let's update
that x count is now set to zero which is
good for us because s1's x count was
also zero so therefore we can actually
increment our number of matches now
right so let's uh set matches now equal
to 21. we also added a character we
added this a character at the top so
let's actually increment the number of
a's we went from having zero a's to now
having one a and that's what we were
looking for right because one a is also
found in s1 count so now we can
increment our number of matches from 21
to b22 we're getting closer to our goal
and i'm gonna kind of fast forward the
remaining two spots clearly we're gonna
see that the y gets chopped off and then
we're gonna be two we're gonna add the b
character which is also what we wanted
to do right we have one b and we have
zero y's so that brings us to be 24
matches and then we're gonna shift one
more time uh to be at this last window
we're gonna get rid of the z that we
that we didn't really need so now our
number of z's is zero that's good that's
exactly what we want and we added a c
character so now we have one c now we
have the exact number of matches we were
looking for that our matches count is
going to be 26 whenever we get to 26
matches that's our magic number we are
going to go ahead and stop the algorithm
and return true because all we're
looking for is does there exist a single
permutation of this in s2 or in other
words does there exist an anagram of s1
and there does we found it we return
true immediately and we can stop the
algorithm that's the big o of end time
algorithm now let's actually code it up
okay now let's write the code but
there's just one little edge case we
actually have to look for that i didn't
talk about previously and that's if our
s1 string is actually shorter or
actually rather longer than our s2
string
which would make it impossible for us to
find a permutation of s1 in s2 in that
case we can just return false
immediately but after that we can get
into our standard algorithm even though
i was talking about hashmaps we can
actually implement these with arrays as
well because we are getting fixed values
uh lowercase a through lowercase z and
we can convert those characters to be
uh integers and we can use those
integers as indices indexes of our two
arrays so initially i'm just going to
set these to be 26
numbers and each of those numbers is
just going to be a 0 for now uh we're
going to go through every character in
s1 and we're gonna go so suppose s1 is
maybe three characters long at the same
time as we're going through s1 we're
also going to go through the first let's
say three characters of s2 so we're
going to initialize both of these hash
maps at the same time so let's do that
now so the way we're going to convert
these characters so in s1 we're going to
get the character at the ith indexed and
we're going to use the ord function now
depending on your language it might be a
different function all we're doing is
getting the ascii value of this
character with our ord function and
we're going to subtract from it the
ascii value of lowercase
lowercase a let's get this right and
this will map to an index this will map
to one of the 26 indexes and to this all
we want to do is just add one to it and
i'm just going to go ahead and copy and
paste this line and do the exact same
thing for s2 we're gonna in s2 count uh
we're going to update the count of this
character and just increment it by one
so now before we actually get to our
sliding window portion don't forget we
actually have to initialize the number
of matches we're initially going to set
it to zero but let's compare
each of these maps or arrays we know
that there's going to be 26 spots in the
array so we can actually just hard code
that so now we're going to say
to the number of matches we want to add
one to it only if
s1 count at index i is equal to s2 count
at index i that's the only case where
we'd want to increment this by 1 but if
that's not the case then we are not
going to increment it by one so we can
just say else zero right so else
incremented by zero which is the same as
not incrementing it at all let's put
parentheses here just to clean it up and
now we can move on so now we're going to
do the sliding window portion we're to
initialize a left pointer to be at the
beginning so at index uh
0. so then we're going to have our right
pointer which is actually going to
iterate through every position in s2
but we know we don't actually have to
start at the first position because we
already initialized our windows so we're
actually going to start at the length of
1 the length of s1 because this will
start us at the next character that we
left off at right and this and this
range is actually non-inclusive so we
stopped before we reached this index so
now we're actually going to go to that
index with our right pointer but
remember what happens if matches is 26
shouldn't we return immediately yeah we
can put a return statement outside of
this for loop but it'll be redundant so
we can actually put it as the first
statement inside of the for loop so
basically if matches is equal to 26 then
we are returning true if that ever
happens we can immediately return true
no questions asked but if it's not the
case then we have to update the number
of matches we know that we just visited
a character at index r and this is the
part where you actually might have hoped
that you used a hash map rather than an
array and that's fine if you want to
rewrite the code that i'm about to write
using hash maps i think it's perfectly
fine but i feel like i usually overuse
hashmap so this time i actually wanted
to kind of show you guys the array
solution even though it's a little bit
more annoying because remember our
character is not the key of our array we
have to map that character to an index
and we can do that just like this so s2
at index r uh minus ord of lowercase a
so we're also going to take the ord of
this because that's how we're getting
the index of our count arrays so now we
can actually use this index but what are
we going to use it for well we know that
this character is the character that was
just added to our uh window in our s2
string so we're gonna increment the
count of this by one but now that we
just incremented the count of it by one
it could be possible that now it exactly
equals the count in s1 so if that's the
case if now that we incremented this and
now it finally equals exactly s1 count
at the same index at the same character
then
we can increment our number of matches
by one but it's possible that also by
incrementing this instead of making it
exactly equal we made it too
large we made it exactly bigger than the
target by one that's how you know we
have got to actually decrement the
number of matches so basically else if
s1
count at the same index plus 1 is now
exactly equal to s2 count at the index
and if this is the case that means they
were equal they were exactly equal but
we just incremented s2 count by one so
now we made them unequal so then we
actually have to decrement the number of
matches by one okay and that's pretty
much the entire algorithm but there's
one last thing and i'm just going to go
ahead and actually copy and paste this
entire block
because we're going to do the exact
opposite thing we know that we're adding
a character to the right of our window
but at index l at index left we removed
a character so we're just going to
replace this with the opposite case
right here i replace the r with an l and
here instead of incrementing the count
we're going to decrement the count
because this is the character that we
just removed from the left side of our
window and here what we're going to say
this is actually going to stay the same
if somehow by decrementing this we made
the counts exactly equal then we're
going to increment our matches by 1. but
if somehow by decrementing this value we
changed it from being exactly equal to
now being too small meaning it's now
going to be equal to s count s1 count
minus 1. if we changed it from being
exactly equal to now being slightly too
small that's when we are going to
decrement the number of matches right so
we really didn't have to make too many
changes to this block of code but that's
actually the entire algorithm except we
know our right pointer is being
incremented by one each time but we also
want to make sure our left pointer is
being incremented by one each time as
well and after that we are done then
finally we can return false well not
quite because it's possible that after
our loop eggs are exited right the last
iteration of our loop we didn't check
after that if our matches were equal to
26 so instead we're actually going to
return
does matches equal 26 so it's going to
return true if it does equal 26 it's
going to return false if it doesn't
equal 26 now let's run the code to make
sure that it works and on the left you
can see that it does and it's pretty
efficient so i really hope that this was
helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it really supports the channel
a lot consider checking out my patreon
where you can further support the
channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching